und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka abend
die ankündigung ist in vieler hinsicht
eine sensation tesla will in deutschland
bauen in brandenburgs genau gesagt in
der kleinen gemeinde grünheide die neue
giga factory grünheide würde dann
künftig in einem atemzug mit shanghai
und silicon valley genannt werden was
die grünheider selbst vermutlich auch
noch nicht ganz fassen können so wie man
überhaupt erst mal nur staunen kann dass
deutschland von einem ausländischen
konzern als standort für eine neue groß
fabrik gewählt wird eigentlich läuft es
eher umgekehrt große firmen wandern ab
in ländern mit niedrigeren löhnen und
weniger auflagen und dann auch noch
ausgerechnet in der automobilindustrie
dem deutschen kerngeschäft schon
nächstes jahr sollen die bauarbeiten
beginnen in berlin werden jetzt schon
wetten angenommen wer schneller fertig
ist die neue kita factory oder der br
mädchen erwarten berichtet so ganz
nebenbei fackelte tesla-chef bei einer
preisverleihung in berlin die nachricht
wir haben entschieden dass wir die tesla
giga fabrik in der region um berlin
bauen werden allen masc milliardär und
visionär schwärmt auf der bühne von
berlin
der pionier im geschäft mit elektroautos
hat deutschland allen anderen bewerbern
um den standort einer neuen fabrik
vorgezogen für ihn eine klare
entscheidungen
jeder weiß dass die deutsche
ingenieurkunst hervorragend ist und das
ist einer der gründe warum wie die giga
fabrik in deutschland bauen
zusätzlich siedeln wir eine entwicklungs
und designzentrum in berlin an
berlin für maske passt die stadt zur
premium marke tesla die produktion geht
nach brandenburg grünheide punktet mit
der nähe zur hauptstadt und dem
flughafen ber hier stehen große
industrieflächen zur verfügung
tesla will grüner werden und brandenburg
produziert genügend ökostrom
bei der produktion die tesla macht zum
teil die beginner factory mit batterien
sind energiekosten und energie sehr sehr
wichtig und dabei energie will man in
der zukunft auf grüne energie setzen und
da hat natürlich brandenburg und der
großraum berlin vorteile
bisher hat tesla hoch automatisierte
fabriken in amerika und china
in brandenburg sollen in zukunft
batterien antrieb unter neues suv
kompaktmodell gebaut werden das passt in
die strategischen planungen von
brandenburg die das neue werk mit
subventionen im rahmen des eu rechts
fördern
es ist eine investition in die zukunft
für unser land eine investition in
zukunftstechnologien sowohl
elektromobilität als auch speicherung
von energie batteriefabrik monatelang
hat die brandenburger landesregierung
verhandelt um tesla nach grünheide zu
locken und damit mehrere tausend
arbeitsplätze
das kommt gut an in der
strukturschwachen region und der
berliner politik ja ich finds gut ich
denke dass es für die entwicklung vor
ort wirklich nur von vorteil sein kann
ja zum einen weil zukunftssichere
arbeitsplätze in deutschland entstehen
zum zweiten weil der automobilstandort
deutschland international weiter
aufgewertet wird
die deutschen autobauer wurden von der
ankündigung überrascht wollen aber die
herausforderung annehmen
wir freuen uns auch über den wettbewerb
den die deutsche automobilindustrie hat
immer gezeigt dass sie in intensiven
wettbewerb innovativ ist stark ist und
weiter wächst schwierigkeiten bei der
produktion und zu ambitionierte
wachstumspläne machten tesla in der
vergangenheit immer wieder zu schaffen
noch ist der bau der giga fabrik eine
ankündigung
da stellt sich noch viele fragen die wir
an einen experten richten wollen zum
frankfurter börsenstudio ist der
bankenanalyst für mit schwerpunkt
automobilindustrie beim bankhaus metzler
jürgen kiefer guten abend edgar julius
lincke warum deutschland welche
strategischen überlegungen stecken dabei
tesla dahinter ich denke das ist
besonders und zum einen wahrscheinlich
zum ersten der wille erstmal einen
knalleffekt zu setzen deutschland als so
richtig keiner
erwartet und dann eben dorthin zu gehen
wo die autoindustrie praktisch zu hause
ist direkt ins haus der großen
wettbewerber und der erfinder des autos
wenn man so will und dann zu sagen hey
jungs jetzt beschäftigt euch bitte mit
mir ich bin jetzt da und ich gehe auch
so schnell nicht mehr weg also ganz nah
wird er denn den deutschen automobil
königin sozusagen offenbar auch nicht
kommen sonst hätte sicher niedersachsen
ich wollte vw oder baden württemberg
oder bayern ausgesucht ja das ist
richtig nur ich denke die gedankengänge
könnten etwa so sein es gehe in die
stadt die eigentlich am liebsten ist die
jugendlichen ist und das ist für die
allermeisten gerade nicht deutschen ist
das eindeutig berlin
es geht ja in zukunft vor allem um junge
arbeitskräfte ich muss junge ingenieure
anziehen
und wir haben ja in zukunft wenig mit
maschinenbau zu tun
also ich muss auch nicht dahin gehen wo
sozusagen die alte industrie sitzt wo
die wohl diejenige sitzen die immer
autos gebaut haben sondern ich kann mir
wirklich den arbeitsplatz oder den platz
für das werk sozusagen frei wählen und
dahin gehen wo ich vielleicht am ehesten
junge leute für mich interessieren kann
werden denn wirklich so viele
arbeitsplätze da entstehen das heißt ja
immer bei den e autos braucht man
eigentlich gar nicht so viele leute die
da bauen
ja man brauche nicht mehr so viele wie
mit bisherigen autos sehr wahrscheinlich
jedenfalls aber man braucht natürlich
einige tausend personen einige tausend
ingenieure arbeiten die auch diese autos
zusammen schrauben und die vor allen
dingen auch entwickeln er wird ja beide
ist er will ja entwicklungszentrum
autowerk und vor allem auch batteriewerk
und dafür braucht man dann schon die 7
8000 personen von denen bisher die rede
ist
ladestation wird er vermutlich auch noch
zusätzliche aufbauen was bedeutet das
für die deutsche automobilindustrie für
den standort hier ja es bedeutet vor
allem für die e-mobilität dass es mit
ihnen ganz klar einen schritt nach vorne
geht
bisher gibt es ja mindestens so viele
zweifler wie die gläubigen an diese
zukunftstechnologie ich denke dieser
schritt zeigt auch dieser schritt zeigt
dass wir ganz klar dabei sind in diese
richtung zu marschieren und dass man das
auch nicht mehr wird aufhalten können
glaube ich und da ist eben
elmers der derjenige der das ganze
praktisch auf die straße gebracht hat
der große pionier der e-mobilität das
hat starke aussagekraft dass er sagt ich
will nach deutschland ich will quasi
mein heil sozusagen auch nach europa
bringen
was glauben sie was da in den zentralen
von bmw daimler vw reagiert wurde leicht
geschockt bei der ankündigung neuer
kurzfristig gestoppt kann ich mir schon
vorstellen man hat glaube ich nicht
damit gerechnet dass ja wirklich
deutschland war macht dass er wirklich
hier hingeht wo sich die platte
platzhirschen natürlich entsprechend
stark fühlen wo sie auch eigentlich eine
unbestreitbare machtposition aufgebaut
haben trotzdem macht das trotzdem traut
sich das zu und ich denke die erste
reaktion war wahrscheinlich wirklich ein
bisschen schock und ein bisschen
ungläubigkeit ist ja tesla auch kein
umstellen umstritten das unternehmen an
die umsätze sind zurückgegangen da gab
es immer auch wieder ausschläge wie
seriös ist das ganze kann ich sehr viel
eventuell auch noch platzen
wir platzen glaube ich nicht die die
ganz entscheidenden ankündigung die er
gemacht hat
die hat ja auch umgesetzt im detail muss
man wirklich sagen da hat vieles dann
nicht gepasst hat er sicherlich oft
worte in den mund genommen die ja nicht
ganz halten konnte
das ist dann schon eine eine gemischte
wegstrecke aber ich denke die großen
linien die großen versprechen die hat ja
auch versucht auf alle fälle umzusetzen
und er wird sich davon glaube ich nicht
mehr abbringen lassen dieses werk hier
zu bauen
die prognose des automobile analysten
jürgen pieper vom bankhaus metzler ich
danken für das gespräch
wenn darüber geklagt wird das im
bundestag oft viele sitzplätze leer sind
wird gerne übersehen dass die
hauptarbeit der deutschen abgeordneten
nicht darin besteht reden zu halten oder
bei reden zuzuhören sondern in den
ausschüssen geleistet wird dort werden
gesetzesvorhaben peniblen diskutiert und
kontrolliert bis sie reif für die
abstimmung im großen plenum sind so weit
so gut doch seitdem die afg im bundestag
ist haben die anderen parteien ein
problem welche afd politiker wählen sie
zu ausschussvorsitzenden der vorsitz des
rechtsausschusses steht üblicherweise
der größten oppositionspartei zu und so
wurde stefan brandner vorsitzender des
rechtsausschusses
seit heute ist er es allerdings nicht
mehr die ausschussmitglieder der anderen
fraktionen konnten und wollten ihn als
ihren öffentlichen repräsentanten nicht
länger ertragen
heike slansky berichtet es war sein
letzter tag als vorsitzender des
rechtsausschusses abgewählt wegen
verbaler entgleisungen eigentlich eine
schmach doch stefan brandner nutzt die
bühne um sich als opfer darzustellen
ich hab meine meinung geäußert meine
damen und herren in deutschland so sagen
sie ihre meinung schwupps sind sie den
job los und genau so läuft das jetzt
hier bundestag eine behauptung jenseits
der realität noch nie wurde ein
vorsitzender abberufen doch brandner hat
nach überzeugung aller anderen parteien
überzogen
das hat sich heute für einen brandner
ausgesetzt die demokratischen fraktionen
haben gemeinsam ein stopp signal gesetzt
bis auf die afd einstimmig das urteil
aller fraktionen brandners provokationen
und grenzüberschreitungen sei nicht mehr
tragbar hat mit unsäglichen tweets gegen
minderheiten gehetzt er hat die
wichtigen gespräche nach dem anschlag in
halle die wir politiker mit
religionsgemeinschaften geführt haben
als herumlungern verächtlich gemacht
brandner selbst nennt sich einen pöbler
mehrfach sorgten seine tweets für ärger
doch dieser retweet war zu viel
warum lungern politiker mit kerzen in
moscheen und synagogen rom nach heftigen
öffentlichen druck entschuldigte er sich
es tut mir leid insoweit doch brandner
twitterte weiter schon damals war seine
wahl zum ausschussvorsitzenden
umstritten
der deutsche anwaltverein hat bereits 20
18 vor seiner wahl darauf hingewiesen
dass wir der meinung sind dass er nicht
für die position des
ausschussvorsitzenden geeignet ist die
fraktionen haben sich damals trotzdem
für ihn ausgesprochen einzelne
fraktionen waren dagegen uns hat dann
eine wahl gegeben nun ist die situation
so wie sie es
wir führen uns von stefan brandner nicht
repräsentiert und er sollte uns auch
nicht länger repräsentieren
insofern ist die abberufung von herrn
brandner ein klares signal gegen hetze
und hass
die idee nutzt den rauswurf kein
schuldbewusstsein keine reue im
gegenteil
unangenehme fragen werden von der
parteispitze brüsk weggebügelt wir haben
nur integre persönlichkeit nicht solche
fragen
ein einmaliger vorgang die afg kann nun
entscheiden wen sie als nachfolger von
brandner für den job des ausschuss
vorsitzenden benennen will
ein einmaliger vorgang doch bisher gab
es auch noch keine ausschussvorsitzenden
die sich so benommen haben
wie umgehen mit kollegen die laufend
tabus brechen sich nicht an spielregeln
halten weil genau das ja auch ihr
politisches markenzeichen ist die
atmosphäre im bundestag hat sich
jedenfalls verändert nicht nur während
der plenarsitzungen in denen es weitaus
aggressiver zugeht als früher
abgeordnete erzählen auch dass sie
vorsichtiger geworden sind was sie sagen
wenn sie in der bundestags kantine
sitzen oder im aufzug stehen
früher habe man da auch mal einen scherz
gemacht oder einen unbedachten spruch
heute müsse man immer damit rechnen dass
jemand zuhört der einem daraus einen
strick drehen will
die grund kollegialität über die
parteigrenzen hinweg sei couchepin und
lars seefeldt haben in den letzten zwei
jahren mehrere abgeordnete begleitet
hier ein auszug ihrer doku sehr geehrter
herr präsident kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe gäste arme menschen sterben früher
amira mohammed ali vor zwei jahren kurz
nach der bundestagswahl und kurz vor
ihrer ersten rede
mittlerweile ist sie neue fraktionschef
in ihrer partei die linke damals übt sie
noch das reden im plenum und den umgang
mit der afd
die würden mich auch nicht gut
dann will ich immer nur zurückführen
aber das ist ja auch nicht gut und ich
kann mich dann irgendwie nicht ich muss
mich zusammenreißen
der ton im bundestag ist rauer geworden
aggressiver es fallen worte die hier
noch nie zu hören waren
statt ausweisung also jetzt papa
gefährde
mama gefährde und die gefährder bambini
die kleinen gehen natürlich zum
staatlichen werteunterricht und
hinterher zu papas enthauptung
unterricht den veränderten ton kann man
sogar messen die stenografen notieren
jeden hohen jedes abfällige gelächter
dieses notierte verlachen war in den
ersten zwei jahren der letzten
wahlperiode fast 600 mal zu hören
im gleichen zeitraum der jetzigen mehr
als dreimal so oft am häufigsten höhnte
die afd gefolgt von der spd und den
grünen
es wird mehr übereinander gelacht und
geschimpft dafür weniger miteinander
verhandelt auch ein beleg dafür
die zwischenfragen ich finde es armselig
wenn sie wie ein bundestags küken
jegliche jegliche zwischenfrage einer
fraktion ablehnen ich finde es armselig
tiere zwischenfragen hier im parlament
die haben wir vor allen dingen einziehen
die haben das ziel der sie noch ein
bisschen mehr die redezeit haben wollen
und noch ein bisschen mehr ihre
schimpftiraden und in diesem fall
übrigens auch ihre unmenschlichkeit
darstellen wollen
in den ersten zwei jahren der letzten
wahlperiode wurden über 80 prozent der
zwischen fragen vom redner zugelassen
seit 2017 werden mehr zwischenfragen
angemeldet und deutlich mehr abgelehnt
über 40 prozent
wer einfache abgeordnete in diesem
bewegten bundestag begleitet der merkt
schnell die sehnsucht nach geordnetem
arbeiten ist groß die aussicht darauf
eher gering
es geht nur noch um rechts oder links
oder vorne oder unten
es geht nur noch um die einfachen
antworten auf schwierige fragen da muss
man sich schon wirklich die frage
stellen wie gehen wir miteinander um
bis 2021 ist dieser bundestag gewählt
zur halbzeit jetzt steckt er weiter
mitten in seiner bewährungsprobe
die ganze doku mit dem schönen titel die
müller so das hohe haus zwei jahre im
deutschen bundestag können sie heute
nacht um 00 45 sehen oder jeder zweite
der mediathek abrufen
das kabinett hat heute auch getagt und
mehrere gesetzesänderungen beschlossen
damit beginnen die nachrichten von heinz
wolf die bundesregierung hat änderungen
im strafrecht auf den weg gebracht die
unerlaubtes fotografieren betreffen
das kabinett beschloss dass es künftig
als straftat verfolgt werden soll wenn
jemand einer frau unter den rock oder
das kleid fotografiert gleiches gilt für
fotos ins dekolleté ebenfalls unter das
strafrecht fällt es demnach bei unfällen
oder unglücken aufnahmen von toten zu
machen und sie zu verbreiten
bislang war nur lebende personen von vor
solchen aufnahmen geschütze der straff
rahmen der geht bis zu zwei jahren haft
ein weiterer kabinettsbeschluss betrifft
die betreuung von grundschülern
von 2025 an soll es von der ersten bis
zur vierten klasse ein anrecht auf eine
ganztagsbetreuung geben in einem ersten
schritt dahin soll nun ein
sondervermögen von zwei milliarden euro
eingerichtet werden um in räumlichkeiten
und gebäude an den schulen zu
investieren
die bundesregierung will in ihrem klima
paket für windkraftanlagen einen abstand
von 1000 metern zur nächsten
wohnbebauung fest schreiben energie und
wirtschaftsverbände kritisieren die
pläne massiv die verbände befürchten
eine schwächung des windenergie ausbaus
sowie den verlust von arbeitsplätzen im
bundestag verteidigte
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier die
pläne der koalition
die politik müssen sich mit dem
widerstand der bürger gegen
windkraftanlagen auseinandersetzen
der konflikt zwischen israel und der
militanten palästinenserorganisation
islamischer dschihad droht sich weiter
zu verschärfen
die miliz feuerte vom gazastreifen aus
heute weitere raketen auf israel ab die
israelische armee reagierte mit
vergeltungsangriffen eine diplomatische
vermittlung lehnte der islamische
dschihad ab einer seiner anführer war
gestern bei einem angriff der
israelischen armee getötet worden
gut einen monat nach dem türkischen
einmarsch in nordsyrien hat us-präsident
trump seinen türkischen kollegen erdogan
im weißen haus empfangen
trump schlug bei dem besuch betont
freundliche töne an und lobte die
waffenruhe im nord süd konflikt
das verhältnis zwischen dem nato partner
türkei und usa ist legen zahlreiche
streitpunkte angespannt unter anderem
bei die usa verbündete der kurden miliz
epg im kampf gegen den sogenannten es
waren von der türkei wird diese als
terrorgruppe angesehen
vor seiner wahl hat wird stammt übrigens
mal öffentlich bekannt dass er bei der
türkei einen wie er sagte kleinen
interessenkonflikt habe ich habe in
istanbul nämlich große gebäude trump
tower diese kleinen großen
interessenkonflikte gibt es immer noch
was trumps eigenen ex sicherheitsberater
john bolton auf einer veranstaltung
letzte woche darüber sinnieren ließ
welche persönlichen und finanziellen
interessen in trams türkei-politik
fließen
es bleibt ein dauerthema dieser
präsidentschaft die frage ob trump sein
amt für persönliche zwecke benutzt bzw
missbraucht darum geht es ja auch bei
der ukraine affäre und dem damit
verbundenen amtsenthebungsverfahren
heute begannen die öffentlichen
anhörungen von zeugen aus washington
matthiesen
sie stehen schlange wie vor dem theater
drinnen haben die republikaner kulissen
aufgebaut sie wollen es wie show
aussehen lassen denn genau das ist es
aus ihrer sicht aber dann kommt einer
der sich nicht hergeben will für ein
spektakel william taylor hat fakten
mitgebracht was er als us botschafter in
der ukraine im sommer selbst erlebte und
penibel festhielt in notizbüchern
überzeugen soll der zeuge so hofft der
demokrat er dem chef der die sitzung
leitet zu einer republikanischen
kollegen verhöhnen den beamten als
gewinner eines castings und beschimpfen
ihn regierungsmitarbeiter sind
beauftragt die politik des gewählten
präsidenten umzusetzen einige elemente
des staatsdienstes haben entschieden
dass nicht der präsident sondern sie das
sagen haben
bill taylor und george kennt im
außenministerium für die ukraine
zuständig bleiben ernst passend zulagen
wenn der präsident einen verbündeten
erpressen und bestechen wollte
ermittlungen zu gunsten seiner
wiederwahl durchzuführen indem er ein
treffen im weißen haus oder auch
hunderte von millionen dollar
militärhilfe verweigert müssen wir das
einfach hinnehmen
dann leisten sie den eid damit das land
weiß dass lügen hier unter strafe steht
das verleiht ihren worten
glaubwürdigkeit alles auch die
militärhilfe sei davon abhängig gewesen
dass präsident zielinski eine
öffentliche verpflichtung abgibt
ermittlungen gegen joe biden anzuordnen
dass so taylor habe ihm der us
botschafter bei der eu unter berufung
auf donald trump gesagt dass der
präsident mehr daran liegt als an der
ukraine
ja das wäre amtsmissbrauch irrtum an die
republikaner die militärhilfe sah ja am
ende ohne gegenleistung geflossen also
dürfe niemand behaupten dass er eine
unabdingbare voraussetzung für das
andere gewesen
sie haben ja nicht vielleicht gesagt
sondern klar das sei so gewesen aber
weder das eine noch das andere ist
passiert also stimmte alles nicht aber
herr jordan als die militärhilfe
zurückgehalten wurde haben wir das
vertrauen unseres engen partners in
unsere verlässlichkeit erschüttert sein
amerikanischer anführer so fragt
daraufhin ein demokrat ausländische
regierungen bitten gegen
ihre politischen rivalen zu ermitteln
macht es das schwieriger für
demokratische werte zu werden
ja es macht es schwieriger für unsere
diplomaten in übersee die politischen
ziele umzusetzen
in welcher weise es geht um die
glaubwürdigkeit wenn sie von diplomaten
vor auch dass eine höhere nun von us
anführern etwas anderes nur wenn die
menschen im land das überzeugend finden
nicht als so abtun finden sich
vielleicht doch 20 republikaner die am
ende im senat mit stimmen für trumps
entfernung aus dem amt
und jetzt nochmal heinz zunächst mit
einer meldung vom sport der deutsche
weitspringer markus rehm hat bei der
para wm der leichtathleten in dubai gold
gewonnen
der als favorit startete setzte sich
damit erfolgreich gegen seine
konkurrenten mit acht metern 7 10 durch
es ist ein fünfter wm titel in serie und
jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten immer ohne gewähr
17 18 20 29 38 44 superzahl 0
und weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf de und initiativtext
außerdem 557 venedig da hat natürlich
jeder sofort bildern kopf die berühmten
gondoliere gehören natürlich auch dazu
ihre gondeln tragen derzeit allerdings
trauer
soweit es nicht sogar zerstört wurden in
der verheerenden hochwasserkatastrophe
die venedig gerade erlebt sogar der
markusdom wurde geflutet
die schäden in der weltkulturerbestadt
werden enorm sein und in venedig weiß
man dass es solche überflutung und
künftig wohl häufiger geben wird annette
hilsenbeck berichtet
sie sind es gewohnt acqua alta das
alljährlich wiederkehrende hochwasser
zum winter hin
doch dieses jahr erreicht dass
rekordhöhe 80 prozent der stadt unter
wasser gondel nun schiffe fortgerissen
solche fluten haben selbst viele
venezianer noch nicht erlebt die
touristen in der stadt scheinen
fasziniert von den fluten vergnügen sich
sogar für die einwohner ist dagegen
schon jetzt klar
dieses mal hat das hochwasser große
schäden angerichtet
am nachmittag als sich das wasser zurück
zieht beginnt dann jedes aki damit sein
jubilaren zu säubern alles nass alles
dreckig sehen sie das wasser hat alles
kaputt gemacht ich hatte ja sachen im
schaufenster und der safe war auch voll
gelaufen um kurz vor mitternacht war das
wasser auf 187 zentimeter über dem
normalen meeresspiegel gestiegen
angetrieben durch heftigen südwind der
das wasser in die kanäle drückte hotels
geschäfte restaurants überall dringt das
wasser ein überwindet sämtliche
schutzvorrichtungen
der schaden werde wohl hunderte
millionen euro betragen so der
bürgermeister heute der markusplatz
steht tief unter wasser
auch der dom überflutet das wasser drang
in die basilika ein floss in die krypta
durch solche extrem hochwasser und ihre
starke strömung befürchten experten für
das bauwerk und sein statikprobleme der
präsident der region sprach heute von
apokalyptischer zerstörung und kündigt
hilfe an
ich hatte schon den katastrophenfall für
venedig aber auch für die gesamte
betroffene region ausgesprochen
und ich habe staatliche hilfe
angefordert und das den notstand
anerkannt wird
jahrelang schon wird an einer flut
sperre vor der küste gebaut die die
lagunenstadt schützen soll das projekt
stoppt es heißt korruption und fehlendes
geld seien schuld derweil soll es auch
heute nacht wieder hochwasser geben
acqua alta wieder herrscht starker
südwind venedig bleibt weiterhin den
fluten ausgeliefert venedig fürchtet
sich vor häufigeren überflutungen und in
australien fürchtet man sich vor
buschbränden die immer heftiger werden
weil große landesteile seit jahren unter
dürre leiden
dazu gibt es gleich eine eindringliche
reportage im auslandsjournal und um 0.35
gibt es dann heute plus mit daniel
bröckerhoff es morgen ab wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schön genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die wärme streifen
von ad hoc ins kennen sie vielleicht
dass hier stellt aber nicht die
atmosphäre drama sondern die
verschiedenen ozeane und zwar vom
arktischen ozean bis zum in dick und
ganz links sehen sie das jahr 1901 und
ganz rechts das jahr 2018
man sieht hier eine ganz eindeutige
verfärbung von blut blaue richtung roth
also es wird immer wärmer und ganz
besonders stark der arktische ozean das
ist ja der bereich auf unserem planeten
der sich am schnellsten und stärksten
erwärmt wir schauen jetzt auf das wetter
und über deutschland gibt es in der
mitte über den mittelgebirgen regen und
schnee bis auf 600 meter herab das
hauptsächlich in der ersten nachthälfte
und danach klart es auf und es wird
spiegelglatte auf den straßen
ganz im süden klart es ebenfalls auf und
dann gehen die temperaturen ordentlich
zurück bis auf minus zehn grad am
alpenrand und 4 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands
dort gibt es morgen viele wolken nach
osten viel sonnenschein im süden muss
erstmal der nebel verschwinden und dann
gibt es auch dort etwas sonne
das bei temperaturen von 3 grad am
alpenrand und 8 grad ganz im westen 9
grad nach osten hin
die nächsten tage am freitag kommt im
süden etwas regen und schnee auf sonst
ist es meist trocken an der nordsee
windig temperaturen 3 bis 14 grad die
höheren temperaturen er im osten ja und
am samstag kommt kräftige regen im
nordwesten auf bei 3 bis 10 grad
damit ein schöner abend